exciting getting off his butt and doing
something about the coming robot
Revolution
today I'm pleased to announce that these
seven companies have agreed volunteer
voluntary commitments for responsible
innovation
these commitments which the companies
will Implement immediately underscore
three fundamental principles
safety security and Trust when the big
guy wasn't being weird he was meeting
with top AI Tech execs and getting them
the pinky promise that they'll put in
safety measures but Terminator director
James Cameron thinks Biden might be too
late when it comes to saving Humanity
from the robots saying this quote I
warned you guys in 1984 and you didn't
listen
I think the weaponization of AI is the
biggest Danger
Greg are you confident that Joe Biden
has AI under control no I don't
oh why are you not confident in that I I
I uh because he's not he's too detached
the administration is detached James
James Cameron's prediction is true uh
it's not that a artificial intelligence
will become super intelligent it will
become super stupid and I I use this
phrase It's called The unbending mind
it's a non-conscious agent that will
focus only on pursuing one goal that
it's a goal that was predicted in The
Terminator what was the thing about
Terminator that was such a great film
couldn't be stopped there's no button to
turn it off it's like you know when you
have your phone and you're sitting here
and you're like and you're watching a
video and all of a sudden it becomes
either disgusting or loud
and you want to turn it off and you
can't you start panicking so annoying
you start panicking that's what's that's
what's going to happen when AI actually
becomes uh so it's self recursive it'll
self-improve at an exponential rate and
all of a sudden it'll have a
Consciousness and imagine taking a
hammer and trying to hit it on a switch
or a button and it won't work that's
what we're going to be feeling that's
the same feeling of this book
goal-oriented missions
um created uh through machine learning
are probably the most dangerous thing
we're going to have to deal with not
like script writing or taking over like
creative things because they'll get
Dumber but when they have one specific
goal watch out they're going to make a
paper clip they're going to make you
into a paper clip you can't make me into
a paperclipse I bet I could I'm not
paper book paper clip material but an AI
wouldn't know that and AI would go like
it's like bend me like some sort of
sausage yes it's called the paperclip
Theory there is a shut off button on
these robots I told you where it is
Katie I think the National Security
implications of this are huge a your own
government using AI against you for
propaganda purposes developing fake
things that they say are true that's a
problem also a huge problem with people
with countries like China or other
adversaries who can use it for
propaganda purposes deep fakes are part
of AI which are a huge problem where
they'll portray like a U.S president
saying something and if they do that
declare war on you know for whatever
reason and there's a misunderstanding
about what's real and what's not and
that devolves into a nuclear situation I
mean their problems endless with the AI
being weaponized
okay I'll go now because they're staring
at me but Craig is totally right about
this getting Dumber thing so there was
this study out of Stanford I get it bad
week for Stanford academics but they
started in March measuring how often
chat GPT would identify the number uh
17077 as a prime number and it was
correct 97.6 of the time it's now down
to 2.4 percent of the time that it's
identifying that correctly so just think
of that drop off in what it's doing in a
matter of three months how much it's
going to progress even further into this
but it's going to be a different kind of
intelligence that can't be measured so
it will be stupid but the one thing it
can do in its own world will be
brilliant
that's truthfully we we all don't really
know right
we're on TV to pretend like we know so
let's go
first of all I am so comfortable that
Joe Biden is deep in on this and that he
got a he got a pinky swear from all
these people who are telling him that
yeah voluntary commitment uh to make
sure that nothing gets out of control
Katie's right it's about National
Security I mean which is a real danger
zone uh but there are some promising
areas with cancer and Medicine uh but my
my question that I have is how come
these directors can figure this stuff
out before we do like in 1996 they had
the net it was about online I love that
remember remember Sandra Bullock yeah
and then in 98 there was Enemy of the
State with Will Smith and that was about
all the surveillance yeah all right and
I think in 98 You've Got Mail that was
the one with Meg Ryan and Tom Hanks yeah
they talked about online dating yeah I
mean as
what I'm saying they kind of like are
ahead of us in this
Cameron's had five failed marriages
didn't predict that
thank you
not call them failure
I had cocaine sharks are coming to a
beach near you
I want to Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now